if you like The Witcher video games
there's a lot you'll like on the Netflix
series too but if you fell in love with
Geralt ciri yennefer and the rest with a
controller in your hand you'll find a
few surprises waiting in the TV
adaptation of these classic polish books
one of the best characters and CD
Projekt Reds games and Andrzej Sapkowski
x' novels is the fashionable womanizing
bard dandelion who somehow one of Geralt
closest friends despite his penchant for
getting into trouble he could die oh
yeah we wouldn't happen he's just as
delightful in the TV show although you
might not immediately recognize him and
Netflix is the Witcher he goes by a
different name
instead of dandelion The Witcher calls
the character yes gear makes sense and
so much that it sort of doesn't there's
a good reason for this and the novel's
original polish yes gear is actually
dandelions name and translates in
English to buttercup
in the games the name dandelion fit well
but the bards flamboyant personality has
been toned down for the show yes gear is
still a scene-stealing rascal but he's
not quite as extravagant as the
dandelion in the games the Netflix show
generally has a more serious grounded
tone and a silly name like dandelion
would stick out like a sore thumb young
man might have mentioned that the road
was too narrow for horses and his
initial sales pitch welcome to the world
yes man for many fans Doug cockle is
Geralt of Rivia the actor has played The
Witcher for a dozen years voicing Geralt
and all three games the card based
spin-off went and a guest appearances in
Soul Calibur 6 and Monster Hunter World
before Henry Cavill took the lead role
for The Witcher TV series he was just
another fan of the video games and he
didn't copy cockles performance for his
take on the character for one Kabul is
British and in the show he speaks with
something close to his natural accent
his tone of voice is also deeper than
cockles whom cavil is described as
having more of a whispery delivery I
wasn't gonna make him American like Coko
performed him in in The Witcher and so I
kind of blended my natural accent with
that gravelly tone cavils Garrett
doesn't sound the same but it still
sounds right that's what really matters
it's not easy being a witch you trust me
I know in The Witcher games Geralt
carries two swords there's a steel one
for regular fights and the silver one
for fighting monsters in the show that
hasn't changed but you're not going to
see Geralt with two swords strapped to
his back very often for the most part
cavils Geralt only carries one sword at
a time that's a note that comes straight
from the books and which Geralt tends to
leave his silver sword on his horse
Roche unless it's a very special
occasion it's also a practical concern
according to The Witcher show's
supervising an armorer Nik Jefferies as
Jefferies said in an interview with
polygon silver is a soft and flimsy
material and wouldn't do much good
during battle it's also pricey and what
attract bandits Geralt already has
enough trouble he doesn't need more in
fact all of the weapons and costumes on
the show were more grounded than their
video game counterparts what works in a
digital world doesn't always work in
live-action and the costume designers
behind the TV show deliberately turned
away from the game style making costumes
and accessories more grounded and
practical they may not be quite as
visually memorable but they hold up a
lot better in a fight The Witcher has a
lot of backstory to get through man
unlike the games it has to appeal to an
audience that's not always willing to
buy into fantasy series showrunner
Lauren Schmidt history told looper you
don't want to alienate people who've
never heard of The Witcher before I
wanted to make sure I was giving it in
bite-sized pieces as such some of the
characters that you know from the games
have been combined or given new roles
for example the wizard Mouse act or
immune as the game calls him can be
found in The Witcher 3 which takes place
after the events of the TV series and
the books he won't play a similar role
in the show though since spoiler alerts
he's killed halfway
the first season you're going to run
into that sort of thing a lot familiar
characters or personalities but remixed
in a way that makes them feel fresh or
new Triss Merigold is one of the very
first people you meet in the first
Witcher game where she's positioned as
Geralt main love interest in The Witcher
3 when Geralt on again off again
girlfriend yennefer finally shows up the
game embraces a legitimate love triangle
players have to choose which of the two
sorcerers they want to romance both make
a strong case just don't try to
double-dip in the end you'll regret it
well if your team trysts we have some
bad news
while yennefer is a major character on
the show Tris is only a bit part and she
and Geralt don't have many sparks as far
as Netflix's series is concerned
jennifer is gerelds one and only it's a
shame to lose all that juicy drama but
honestly The Witcher is busy enough as
it is a love triangle is a nice way to
break up a 90 hour game but the show
only has eight episodes there are more
important things to spend that time on
if you only know geralt and yennefer
romance from The Witcher 3
you probably think a genie made them
fall in love after all that's the main
thrust of the side quests the last wish
which serves as a sequel to the
sapkowski's short story of the same name
in the quest geralt and yennefer hunt to
gin in order to undo the wish that bound
the two together when you succeed you
can either continue romancing yennefer
or dumper it's your call
the game implies that magic made geralt
and yennefer get together on the show
it's a lot more complicated like a lot
episode 5 bottled appetites depicts
Geralt in Jennifer's first meeting and
while it does feature Geralt saving
Jennifer's life by calling on a Djinn
the wish itself is ambiguous as in the
books you don't hear exactly what Geralt
wished for further it's pretty clear in
the show that Geralt has feelings for
yennefer the elves charade and flat-out
says as much and geralt and yennefer 's
mutual attraction turns out to be
important to the plot Geralt risks his
life for yennefer because he likes her
and yet AFER's flirty dialogue hints
that she feels the same way the genie
might seal the deal but the sparks are
already fly check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you